hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about amino acid
structure so the first thing i want you
to know with amino acids
is that they are the building blocks of
proteins
so proteins are made up of these
monomers
called amino acids remember that
monomers are the building blocks the
repeating units
that make up polymers protein is a
polymer their specific monomer that
makes
them up are the amino acids and it is
those amino acids that are our focus
today
now an amino acid is a carbon
with four attachments and they have to
be fairly specific
first of all i want to talk to you about
this carbon this carbon that's in the
center
of these four attachments sometimes it's
called the center carbon
but it's more proper name is the alpha
carbon so i'm just going to put a little
greek letter alpha right there
that's the alpha carbon is the central
carbon
and as i said it has four attachments
now
three of these are the same
in all amino acids so in all amino acids
these three groups are present you've
got the hydrogen
i'll put it here on top
an amino group i'll put it right here
and a carboxyl group i'll put it over
here
now i want to point out a few things
before we move on to the fourth group
so first of all um it is
standard notation to write sort of from
left to right
the amino group on the left of the alpha
carbon and the carboxyl group on the
right
of the alpha carbon so you should go n c
c n c c and that should be the
correct order there um sometimes the
hydrogen's on the
on the bottom but it's usually on the
top and the fourth group we talk about
in a second is usually on the bottom
although you will occasionally see those
switched um
but as long as you have the amino on the
left and the carboxyl group on the right
that is the most correct way and then
most often you see the hydrogen on the
top
so do keep in mind there are two carbons
here
and they're different this one is the
alpha carbon that everything is attached
to and this is the carbon of the
carboxylic acid
so that carboxyl group or carboxylic
acid group
i just want to point out here the name
right this is i'm drawing for you here
an amino acid and look at these groups
amino acid this is actually where it
gets its name is the fact that it has an
amino group
and an acid group a carboxylic acid
group
and so that's our amino acid so this is
what every amino acid looks like
except for what's down here now the
fourth
component is
the r group okay the r group
and the r group differs between amino
acids so between the different amino
acids things like
glycine asparagine aspartate
serine cysteine etc all of this is the
same
and it's the r group that changes
so the r groups can fall into four
different categories
they can be nonpolar
so for example if it's just a simple
hydrogen or a methyl group or here we
have a more
a little bit more complicated branch
carbon chain
these would make up glycine alanine
valene but those are all nonpolar
and i do want to point out that glycine
when the r group is an h is the only
time when you've got
sort of um two hydrogens here usually
it's just one hydrogen
and then a more complex r group but that
r group can be a hydrogen
in the specific case of the amino acid
glycine
now the r group can also be polar
so in addition to being nonpolar
there being non-polar possibilities
there are polar possibilities so for
example we've got serine
cysteine i believe that's asparagine
and they are polar r groups so they have
polar characteristics so just like the
nonpolar ones
would be hydrophobic for example the
polar ones are going to be hydrophilic
so they
these amino acids will take on the
characteristics
of their particular r group they can
also be
acidic
so right here i have aspartate also
known as aspartic acid
this is the r group that you would see
in this position for that amino acid
and the reason it's acidic is because
when you drop that into a solution of
water
this h plus right here can come off
and that um you know we know that any
any compound that increases the
concentration of hydrogen ions in a
solution is an acid so that's what's
happening right there
i also want to point out that you've got
um
a carboxylic acid group that's part of
every amino acid there are a couple
of amino acids that have an additional
sort of a second
carboxylic acid group that's part of
their
r group along with some other pieces
and then finally in addition to nonpolar
polar and acidic you can probably guess
this one
they can also be basic
for example this one right here is basic
and it's basic because you've got this
amino group on the end notice again an
amino group
all amino acids have that amino group
to the left of that alpha carbon but a
few
also can have amino groups here's
another one up here
as part of their r group and so this one
it's it's basic because it can actually
accept a proton and become positively
charged
so this nh2 becomes nh3 plus and
anything that reduces the concentration
of hydrogen ions in a solution
by adding one onto this amino group
that makes it a base because it's a
proton acceptor
so that's an example of a basic one now
i also want to show you how two amino
acids
join via something called a dehydration
synthesis reaction
so what does this look like well i'm
going to
just draw a
basic amino acid right here
i'm going to say basic i'm not talking
about basic i just mean general a
general
general structure of an amino acid
and i'm going to call this one make its
r group i'm just going to call it r1
just to distinguish it from another one
and then i've got
another one that i'm just going to draw
generally here
and i'm going to call its r group r 2
just to distinguish it from
the r1 over here so what happens
when you put two of these together how
do they
join together and form something called
a peptide bond
well it's through something called a
dehydration synthesis reaction
you actually have this oh from
the carboxyl group of the first amino
acid
and one of these h's from the amino
group of the second amino acid
these two things join together
to form water
and so water is a
product of this reaction so now we've
got this h
and this oh and they've joined together
to
make water i'm going to
remove them here and then a peptide bond
forms right here between
the carbon of the carboxyl group
of the first amino acid and the nitrogen
of the amino group
of the second amino acid and this right
here is called
a peptide bond
now it's also a covalent bond because
electrons are shared so it's just a
particular type of of covalent bond
and then i mentioned earlier in this
video
about the ncc that's also something
you'll see
repeating along the backbone of a
protein so with a polypeptide
protein for polypeptide
you'll see n c c n c c n c
c n c c and the bond that separates one
ncc from another ncc that's the peptide
bond for two amino acids
have joined together via that
dehydration synthesis reaction
called a dehydration reaction because a
water molecule is kind of pulled out
and is one of the products of the
reaction so if you are interested in
these topics i also encourage
you to check out my video on the four
levels of protein structure
where you will hear quite a bit more
about these r groups and how they
interact to have a protein
gain the correct structure which allows
it to
carry out its correct functions and i
also have a separate video on
dehydration
reactions uh and the the flip side of
that
um the hydrolysis reaction which is how
you break a bond like a peptide bond i
have a video on dehydration synthesis
reactions and hydrolysis reactions
so please check those out thanks for
watching biology professor and i'll see
you next time